EVAN HEPLER-SMITH:
I'm Evan Hepler-Smith.
I'm originally from
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
And I'm in the program
in History of Science
at Princeton.
I'm in my fifth year.
I study the naming of
chemical substances.
Nomenclature is something
that every chemist
has to study still.
For a long time, chemists
had to study quite a bit
about nomenclature.
They spent a lot
of time memorizing
rules of nomenclature,
rules for naming, creating
policy syllabic,
long, sprawling names.
I study where that collection
of rules came from.
At very end of my
undergraduate career,
I took a course in the
sociology of science.
And that, a light
bulb clicked on.
And I realized
that the same sorts
of methods I was learning to
study how literary texts were
put together from
the sentence level
all the way up to the level of
how narratives are constructed
could be used to study
something like science, how
scientific knowledge is made.
MICHAEL GORDIN: When
I first met Evan,
which was before he actually
applied to graduate schools,
he was looking at
various programs.
Within five minutes
of talking to him,
it was clear that he had the
knowledge of organic chemistry
that was well beyond what an
ordinary undergraduate who
majored in it would have.
And it's largely self-taught.
It's a characteristic
of Evan that he
is able to pick up enormous
amounts of information
by sheer application and will
power and a set of native gifts
that you will already be able
to see in other contexts.
EVAN HEPLER-SMITH:
During the period
that I study from
1880s to 1940 or so,
nomenclature wasn't tedious.
And that's what's interesting
about this particular period.
That's why I chose these
beginning and end dates.
There was a period of about 40
or 50 years in which chemists
from the most senior, august
scholars in Europe to chemists
teaching in high schools felt
that nomenclature was something
that was both very important,
worth thinking about,
and up for grabs.
But I think that attending to
historical examples in which
something goes from being
an object of public debate
to the technical, boring
business of specialists
is a really important
place to look.
Because the politics attendant
on that transformation
determine what is
in and out of bounds
of debate for the
public, for scientists,
for people who might potentially
have an interest in rules that
are being made about how
information is organized
and shared at many
different levels.